>> Dana: I AM DANA PERINO.
THIS IS A FOX NEWS ALERT.
TERRIFYING ORDEAL AND THE SKIES,
SOUTHWEST AIRLINES JETBLUE AND
ENGINE TODAY IN MIDAIR WHILE ON
ITS WAY TO NEW YORK CITY, LIVING
IN OPENING THE PLANE THAT NEARLY
SUCKED SOMEBODY OUT.
ONE PASSENGER IS DEAD.
JULIE BANDERAS JOINS US FROM OUR
NEWSROOM WITH THE FULL STORY.
JULIE.
>> THAT'S RIGHT, ONE PERSON
DIED, SEVERAL INJURED.
THIS SOUTHWEST AIRLINES JET, THE
ENGINE EXPLODED IN MIDAIR.
30,000 FEET IN THE SKY.
THE FLIGHT FROM NEW YORK TO
DALLAS MADE AN EMERGENCY LANDING
IN PHILADELPHIA THIS MORNING.
IN THE THICK OF IT ALL, A
HARROWING RESCUE IN MIDAIR.
MULTIPLE REPORTS, WITNESSES SAW
A PIECE OF SHRAPNEL FROM THE
ENGINE BLEW OUT A WINDOW AND A
FEMALE PASSENGER WAS PARTIALLY
SUCKED OUT OF THE WINDOW BEFORE
HER FELLOW FLYERS SCRAMBLED TO
HER RESCUE.
SHE UNFORTUNATELY LATER DIED,
STILL UNKNOWN WHAT HER INJURIES
WERE THAT CAUSED HER DEATH,
SADLY.
LISTEN TO ONE PASSENGER DESCRIBE
HIS HORROR STORY.
>> TOTALLY SURREAL.
MY WIFE IS IN HER THIRD
TRIMESTER WITH OUR FIRST CHILD.
I SPENT A LOT OF FLYING TIME
TRYING TO ARTICULATE WHAT I
WANTED MY WORDS TO BE TO MY
UNBORN CHILD.
TO MY WIFE.
MY PARENTS.
>> UNBELIEVABLE.
THE FAA SAYS THE EMERGENCY
LANDING ON FLIGHT 1380 HAPPENED
AT 11:20 THIS MORNING AFTER THE
CREW REPORTED DAMAGE TO THE
ENGINE, FUSELAGE, AND WINDOW.
PASSENGER SEEN EXITING THE PLANE
USING THE AIR STAIRS.
SOME PASSENGERS HAVE BEEN
SHARING THEIR HARROWING STORIES
ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
MARTY MARTIN AS LIVE ON
FACEBOOK.
YOU SEE HIM WEARING AN OXYGEN
MASK.
"ENGINE EXPLODED IN THE AIR AND
BLUE OPEN WINDOW 3 FEET AWAY
FROM ME.
IMAGINE THAT."
HE SAYS THE EXPLOSION INJURED A
FEMALE SITTING IN THE SEAT NEXT
TO THE WINDOW.
THE PLANE DEPARTED FROM
LaGUARDIA, TRACKING DATA SHOWS
IT WAS HEADING WEST OVER
ABRUPTLY TURNING TOWARD
PHILADELPHIA.
DANA COMEAU NEW LOOK AT THESE
PICTURES, YOU HAVE TO WONDER HOW
INCREDIBLE AND HOW MANY HEROES
WERE ON BOARD THAT PLANE, NOT
JUST THE PILOTS TO LAND WITH ONE
ENGINE, BUT THE CREWMEMBERS AND
PASSENGERS ON BOARD THAT TRIED
TO SAVE THIS WOMAN.
SADLY, SHE LATER DIED AT THE
HOSPITAL.
>> Dana: IS A CONFIRMED IT WAS
THE SAME WOMAN?
>> WE DO BELIEVE IT IS THE SAME
WOMAN BUT WE DON'T KNOW EXACTLY
WHAT THE CAUSE OF HER DEATH WAS.
WHAT WE DO KNOW SHE WAS HIT IN
THE HEAD BY SHRAPNEL.
WE DON'T KNOW IF SHE WAS
CONSCIOUS OR NOT WHEN SHE WAS
SUCKED THROUGH THE WHOLE OF THE
WINDOW.
IT'S A VERY HORRIFYING STORY.
>> Dana: THANK YOU, APPRECIATE
YOUR REPORTING.
THE NTSB IS ON THE GROUND.
IT'S THE FIRST PASSENGER
FATALITIES SINCE 2009 ON THE
U.S. AIRLINE.
>> Kimberly: PRETTY GOOD TRACK
RECORD.
VERY SAD.
OUR THOUGHTS AND PRAYERS GO TO
THE FAMILY OF THE WOMAN WHO IS
DECEASED, THE REPORTING JULIE
JUST DID.
OBVIOUSLY AIRPLANES ARE SAFE.
PEOPLE SAY GENERALLY FLYING IS
SAFER THAN DRIVING BUT SOMETIMES
THESE TYPE OF CATASTROPHES,
UNFORESEEN, CAN HAPPEN.
WE SEE HERE, PEOPLE JUMPING AND
TRYING TO HELP ONE ANOTHER.
THE THOUGHTS AND REFLECTIONS
ABOUT YOUR LIFE.
YOU GET UP IN THE MORNING.
WE EXPECT WE ARE GOING TO GO TO
BED THAT NIGHT.
GIVES YOU A BIT OF PAUSE TO SAY
SOMETIMES TOTALLY RANDOM THINGS
CAN HAPPEN.
OUT OF THE BLUE, AND IN THE
BLUE, LIKE THIS SITUATION.
THEY WILL DO A FULL AND THOROUGH
INVESTIGATION, GET ALL THE
FORENSICS, FIND OUT WHAT
HAPPENED, AND THEN THERE WILL BE
ISSUES AS TO WHETHER OR NOT
THERE'S ANY CULPABILITY,
LIABILITY AND POWDER SOUTHWEST.
IN TERMS OF ENGINE LOGS OR
RECORDS, MAINTENANCE LOGS FOR
THE AIRPLANE.
TO DETERMINE IF THERE IS ANY
KIND OF FOREWARNING THAT
SOMETHING MIGHT'VE BEEN WRONG
BEFORE THIS HAPPENED.
>> Juan: DANA, WHEN YOU SAID
NOTHING SINCE 2009, YOU ARE
EXACTLY RIGHT.
BUT FOR ME, IS A FREQUENT FLYER
GAMBLER, I ALWAYS THINK IF I GET
ON A BIG PLANE, I'M NOT GOING TO
HAVE A PROBLEM.
THE SMALL PLANES, GOING BACK TO
'09, THERE WAS A SMALL PLANE
THAT HAD A DEICING PROBLEM IN
BUFFALO.
BEFORE THAT, YOU GO BACK TO
2006, AND IT WAS A SMALL PLANE
COMING OUT OF KENTUCKY.
IT HAD A SHORT RUNWAY, DIDN'T
QUITE GET UP AND THEN CRASHED.
THEN YOU LOSE, I THINK IN MOST
CASES, YOU LOST 45, 50 PEOPLE.
IN THIS CASE, YOU ARE IN A BIG
PLANE, BOEING 737.
THEY NEVER HAVE PROBLEMS.
I DON'T KNOW WHEN THE LAST TIME
THE ENGINE EXPLODED.
YOU NEVER HEAR THIS.
IT'S AN EXTRA ORDINARY EVENT FOR
PEOPLE WHO FLIGHT.
WE ALL THINK AMERICAN AVIATION
IS SO SAFE.
THE BIG PLANES NEVER HAVE A
PROBLEM.
>> Dana: PEOPLE WORRY ABOUT
PROPS.
>> Juan: I DON'T LIKE GETTING
ON A LITTLE PLANE, BUT THIS IS A
BIG ONE.
>> Jesse: IT'S WHY I ONLY FLY
PRIVATE.
REALLY THE ONLY WAY TO GO.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Dana: THAT IS GOOD TO KNOW,
JESSE.
>> Kimberly: EVERY MAN, SO
RELATABLE.
>> Juan: A MAN OF THE PEOPLE.
>> Dana: LEAVING NEW YORK ON
THE WAY TO DALLAS, AND THEN TO
PHILLY, PROBABLY A LONG
20 MINUTES.
>> Jesse: I HAVE HAD THIS
HAPPEN TO ME ONCE.
IT WASN'T OBVIOUSLY THE SEVERE
BUT I REMEMBER TEXTING MY
MOTHER, SAYING "I LOVE YOU,"
THINKING I WAS GOING TO GO DOWN.
>> Greg: WHAT DID SHE TEXT
BACK?
>> Kimberly: WHAT WAS THE MOM
TEXT?
>> Jesse: WHEN THEY ARE DOING
THE SAFETY DEMONSTRATION, PAY
ATTENTION.
YOU ARE IN THE EXIT ROW, YOU
DON'T KNOW HOW TO OPERATE THE
AIR MASK.
IT'S IMPORTANT.
LOOKS LIKE THERE WERE A LOT OF
HEROES OUT THERE.
YOU TAKE SAFETY FOR GRANTED WHEN
YOU FLY IN THIS COUNTRY.
THIS NEVER HAPPENS IN AMERICA,
AND IT SHOULDN'T HAPPEN IN
AMERICA.
WE ARE TO ADVANCE INTO
WELL-REGULATED.
OBVIOUSLY THIS WAS A FREAK
ACCIDENT.
IN THE INVESTIGATION IS GOING TO
SHOW WHAT HAPPENED.
BUT YOU HEAR ABOUT THIS AND
OTHER COUNTRIES A LOT, AND
AFRICA AND EGYPT, MALAYSIA,
UKRAINE.
IT SPEAKS TO HOW KIND OF
ADVANCED AND PROFICIENT THE
AMERICAN AIRLINE INDUSTRY IS.
I HOPE SOUTHWEST DOES RIGHT BY
THESE PASSENGERS AND GIVES THEM
MORE THAN A FREE UPGRADE FOR THE
NEXT LIGHT.
THEY HAVE TO TAKE CARE OF THESE
PEOPLE.
THIS IS ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WILL LEAVE YOU SCARRED FOREVER.
THE STOCK PRICE HAS TAKEN A HUGE
SLIDE TO MAKE A MURDER COVERED A
LITTLE BIT.
SOUTHWEST RAINED REALLY HIGH,
ACCORDING TO THE OTHER AIRLINES.
BUT IF THE SAME TIME, THEY'VE
HAD A LOT OF P.R. DISASTERS.
THEY'VE HAD COMPUTERS CRASHED.
THEY'VE HAD THESE EMOTIONAL
SUPPORT DOGS BITE PEOPLE.
THEY HAVE HAD FIGHTS, HAD TO
DRAG WOMEN OUT, THEY WERE
FIGHTING AND KICKING AND
SCREAMING.
THE OVERBOOKED FLIGHTS.
THEY DON'T DO THAT ANYMORE.
HOPEFULLY SOUTHWEST CAN RECOVER
FROM THIS, AND ALL THESE PEOPLE
I HOPE ARE RECOVERING TOO.
>> Dana: GREG, ONE THING
THAT'S DIFFERENT NOW EVEN SINCE
2009, THE LAST TIME THERE WAS OF
ITALIAN PLANE, SOCIAL MEDIA AND
NOW ALLOWS YOU TO ACTUALLY BE
EXPERIENCING IT AND SING IT.
-- SAYING IT.
AS JULIE WAS SAYING, IT'S QUITE
CARING.
WE PROBABLY WOULDN'T HAVE KNOWN
IT BEFORE.
>> Greg: WE PROBABLY WOULDN'T
HAVE LEAD WITH IT.
I DON'T THINK WE SHOULD HAVE LED
WITH THE STORY.
THERE ARE 40 MILLION FLIGHTS A
YEAR, NOT A SINGLE COMMERCIAL
JET FATALITY IN 2017.
BUT YOU CAN'T LEAD A SHOW WITH
FLIGHTS THAT LAND SAFELY.
BECAUSE THAT'S BORING.
BUT YOUR .., IT IS A VERY GOOD
POINT, YOU HAVE THE VIDEO THAT
MAKES IT MORE INTERESTING.
SOMETIMES IT MAKES A STORY
BIGGER THAN IT SHOULD BE.
IN MANY DIFFERENT WAYS.
>> Jesse: , YOU SEE THE FLIGHT
TRACKER'S COMING TO THE VIDEO,
ALL THE FLIGHTS GOING EVERY INCH
OF THE COUNTRY, HOW SAFE IT
ACTUALLY IS.
NEVER HAPPENS.
THOUSANDS OF FLIGHTS UP IN THE
AIR ALL AT ONCE.
IT'S AMAZING HOW THEY ARE ABLE
TO SURE EVERYONE LANCE SAFELY.
>> Greg: 600,000 PEOPLE DIE
EVERY YEAR FROM HEART DISEASE.
I GUESS THAT'S NOT AS EXCITING A
VISUAL.
>> Juan: THERE IS SOMETHING
SERIOUS HERE.
MY OLD BOSS, BEN BRADLEY, USED
TO SAY WE DON'T COVER ALL OF THE
SAFE LANDINGS.
THAT'S YOUR POINT.
AT THE SAME TIME, UNDERSTAND
WHAT HAPPENS WITH SOMEONE
WHAT HAPPENS WITH SOMEONE IN A
WINDOW SEAT BEING PULLED OUT OF
THE WINDOW WHILE THE PLANE IS IN
THE AIR, GREG, AND OTHER PEOPLE
ARE OVER THERE.
ACCORDING TO THE ACCOUNTS ON
BOARD, SHE WAS BLEEDING.
THERE'S BLOOD ALL OVER.
IT'S A PRETTY WILD EXPERIENCE.
>> Dana: WHAT HAPPENS,
KIMBERLY, FROM THE LEGAL
STANDPOINT.
THE SOUTHWEST LAWYERS, NTSB
LAWYERS ET CETERA AND POSSIBLY
FOR THE PASSENGERS?
>> Kimberly: OBVIOUSLY THERE'S
PROBABLY GOING TO BE A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF CIVIL
LAWSUITS.
IT'S GOING TO DEPEND ON THE
RESULTS OF THE INVESTIGATION,
WHAT THEY DETERMINED HAPPENED.
WHETHER IT WAS HUMAN ERROR OR
ANY KIND OF CONSCIOUS DISREGARD
FOR KNOWN RISK.
ACTING IN DEFIANCE OF THAT OR
NEGLIGENCE OR SAYING WE WILL LET
THIS PLANE FLY FOR HOWEVER MANY
MORE HOURS WHEN PERHAPS THEY
SHOULDN'T HAVE.
WE DON'T KNOW THIS BUT THESE ARE
THE TYPE OF THINGS THEY WILL BE
LOOKING FOR IN TERMS OF THE
RECORD.
THEY ARE PRETTY SCRUPULOUS IN
TERMS OF HOW WE KEEP OUR RECORDS
AND THE FLIGHT TRACKING,
MAINTENANCE.
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT BECAUSE ONE
TIME IS ONE TIME TOO MANY.
IF YOU LET A PLANE GO UP AND
THEY AIR AND CLEARED TO FLY AND
SOMETHING IS TERRIBLY AMISS.
THINGS CAN HAPPEN IN GENERAL.
IF THERE'S ANY IDEA OF SOMETHING
THAT'S MALFUNCTIONING OR ENGINE
LIGHTS GOING ON OR SOMETHING
LIKE THAT, VERY CURIOUS TO SEE
THE FLIGHT HISTORY FOR THE PAST,
SAY, 50 OR 100 FLIGHTS THAT THIS
PARTICULAR AIRPLANE WENT ON.
GENERALLY SPEAKING, PHENOMENAL
AERONAUTICS FOR A 737.
PROVED TO BE VERY RELIABLE,
TREMENDOUS SAFETY RECORD.
WE'LL HAVE TO SEE WHAT WENT
WRONG HERE AND HOW SOUTHWEST CAN